.
IT STARTS RIGHT NOW.
>> Ben: THANK YOU, SHANNON AND
WELCOME TO FOX NEWS PRIME TIME.
YESTERDAY I CAME TO YOU TO TALK
ABOUT THE 1970s, HOW MUCH THEY
RESEMBLE OUR CHALLENGE TODAY AND
HOW THEY ARE DIFFERENT.
TONIGHT I WANT TO GO BACK A
LITTLE FURTHER IN OUR HISTORY.
60 YEARS AGO LAST WEEK IN A RARE
MIDDAY JOINT SESSION ON
CAPITOL HILL,
PRESIDENT JOHN F. KENNEDY SET AN
INCREDIBLE GOAL FOR THE NATION.
HE ANNOUNCED TO THE CONGRESS
THAT I BELIEVE THAT THIS NATION
SHOULD COMMIT ITSELF TO
ACHIEVING THE GOAL BEFORE THIS
DECADE IS OUT OF LANDING A MAN
ON THE MOON AND RETURNING HIM
SAFELY TO EARTH.
>> NO SINGLE SPACE PROJECT IN
THIS PERIOD WILL BE MORE
IMPRESSIVE TO MANKIND OR MORE
IMPORTANT TO THE LONG-RANGE
EXPLOSION OF SPACE AND NONE WILL
BE SO DIFFICULT OR EXPENSIVE TO
ACCOMPLISH.
BUT IN A VERY REAL SENSE, IT
WILL NOT BE ONE MAN GOING TO THE
MOON.
WE MAKE THIS JUDGMENT
AFFIRMATIVELY, IT WILL BE AN
ENTIRE NATION.
ALL OF US MUST WORK TO PUT HIM
THERE.
>> Ben: IT'S WORTH YOUR TIME
TO WATCH THE SPEECH AND NOT JUST
TO LAUGH AT LBJ WORKING SO HARD
TO BE IN EVERY FRAME.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT COMES NOT JUST
FROM A DIFFERENT TIME, BUT FROM
A DIFFERENT COUNTRY.
IN HIS CALL FOR A PROJECT OF
IMMENSE NATIONAL IMPORT
PRESIDENT KENNEDY COMES ACROSS
AS A LEADER OF A FREE PEOPLE
COMMITTING US TO A CLEAR EYED
TASK OF ACHIEVING SOMETHING THAT
SEEMED UTTERLY IMPOSSIBLE.
HE HAS NONE OF THE LECTURING
ATTITUDE OF PHILOSOPHER KING
WANT TO BE BARACK OBAMA, THE
BOMBAST OF A REALITY SHOW STAR
LIKE DONALD TRUMP OR THE WEARY
OLD MAN SHAKES FIST AT CLOUD
ENERGY OF JOE BIDEN.
INSTEAD OF PATRONIZING THE
AUDIENCE, HE WALKS THEM WITH
CLEAR LANGUAGE TRICKS LANGUAGE
IMPORTANT.
HE SPEAKS TO US AS CITIZENS, NOT
SUBJECTS.
KENNEDY C